hey everybody Welcome to parks and
recollection I am Rob Lowe and I do have
a very very very special announcement a
lot of people say that they say it on
commercials they say it everybody has a
special announcement everybody's got
something special say I promise you when
I'm done with this announcement you will
go
that was kind of special and the
announcement is this
we are now joined officially
by the great Jim O'Hare
and Greg Levine they are going to steer
this ship
better than the captain of the Titanic I
promise that welcome guys it's great to
have you on board it's so great to be
here I have been a fan of what you guys
have been doing
um everyone knows I do love Parks and
Recreation and uh what you and Alan have
done and Greg because I hear Greg a lot
on these shows too correct yes
uh so uh uh big shoes to fill but I'm
gonna do what I can you know Greg we
think is the secret weapon
um he's like The Wizard of Oz he really
is you don't really see him very much
but when he talks you sit up and listen
yeah
[Laughter]
Levine and and Jim no one's more beloved
on a show of beloved characters than
than Jerry gergich how many games did
Jerry have eventually Jerry Gary Larry
Terry and even Barry from uh uh Johnny
karate that's right yeah but I believe
it's always been gergich it has always
been gurgates although gergis has been
spelled differently oh I'm sure so has
Gary yes that's right
g-e-r-r-g-a-r-y yeah all sorts of stuff
uh yeah I'm a blessed dude uh the Jerry
Gary whatever the hell name character
um has become
um what people consider like just the
sweetest damn person in the whole world
and then they meet me and reality hits
for for those of you who don't know you
know um Jim went directly to prison
yes for crimes committed on on the set
yes I think you've rehabilitated
yourself well uh you can almost live up
to your on-screen reputation now I'm
very proud of what I've done in prison I
took it serious I am proud of what got
you there are you what's that are you
proud of what got you there I am proud
of what got me there and there's every
chance I'll be going back and uh okay
well I made some friends let's just say
that I made some friends uh no I'm
terrified now to be in the studio you
should be I know how to do things yeah I
know how to do things uh yeah uh you
know but I'm really excited Rob I know
this is um you know you guys have been
doing this and you know it and I'm
terrified and excited all of the above
because you guys have done it so well
well we we could not be um passing the
Baton to to two more qualified hilarious
people I'm not going anywhere I'm I'm
I'm I'm still going to be lurking in the
wing you're never gonna know I think
it's gonna be fun because you're never
gonna know when I'm going to show up I'm
nervous all of a sudden I felt like I
didn't have to be nervous and now I
really am yeah he has a key to your
house right yeah but that's a whole
different thing okay